hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Teen Wolf episode 10 video there
was a whole lot of stuff that happened
including them changing the air date of
the episode to be before the VMAs they
decided to air it ahead of the VMAs just
because I guess they thought everyone
would be sleeping through Monday it was
a little bit weird and I feel like all
the people who watch the VMAs were
probably already Teen Wolf fans so it
seems a little ridiculous but whatever
let's talk about the one true alpha
so careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet but I'm gonna
start with my top five moments it's all
wait just a sec okay everybody ready
here we go number five Bret is back it
was a nice callback to the events of
episode 5 remember Bret is from Liam's
old school and even though Scott kind of
saved his life he still got a giant chip
on his shoulder I'm a little bit
confused about the Liam rage situation
but I'm assuming those two have buried
the hatchet in someone's face remember
Deadpool but things have escalated to
the point where assault teams of hunters
are now going after packs it did seem
like Brett and that girl who may or may
not have been his sister were part of
Satomi's pack or they might become part
of a new pack because I think that
Satomi's all pack was completely killed
out by the virus I feel like Brett was a
stand-in for rageface Liam in the
episode because whenever you have like a
team-based episode and there's a war
going on one of the characters has to go
crazy
it's like Reservoir Dogs one of the team
members has to flip out it's like an
unspoken TV rule speaking of which
number four Liam is still losing his
mind
it was totally sweet to see Scott step
up and be the big brother when Liam went
into puppy mode like he wants to crawl
under his bed and just hide till it's
all over I do think it was good that
they let Scott acknowledge all their
dead friends you know not everyone gets
a happy ending I think Liam story was
just all about setting up a big hero
moment in the last two episodes like
he'll figure out how he fits into
Scott's world and start to think of the
pack of his true family and take the
call to action you know turn into a hero
Derek Liam Kira even Bret they'll all be
back for season five the real person
that I think is marked for death is
Satomi which leads me to number three so
Tomy is an alpha without a pack and
three things that won't stay hidden I
feel like her three things were the
foreshadowing that she's gonna sacrifice
herself to save Scott who else here
feels like of all the crazy things that
could go down in the finale Peter will
get his alpha powers back and be like a
crazy villain in season 5 obviously he
said he wants to
Scot but there are two alphas on the
show right now and of those two which
one do you think that the show is going
to keep spoiler alert probably the star
of the show I didn't really see it quite
as clearly until Satomi explained the
Sun the moon and the truth to Chris
instead of being this really Zen mantra
it sounded like Satomi truly believes
that her wolf nature will ultimately
consume her and she'll start ripping
everyone up like she did in the
flashbacks to oak creek when you look at
a genre show like Teen Wolf they're just
a couple big arcs that you can give
characters their hero arts villain arcs
and tragic arcs here arcs are for people
like Liam someone who accepts the call
to action to become a hero and then the
villain arcs are for people like Peter
when they show their true nature and
tragic arcs are for the people who are
destined to die they've been teasing
Derek but I think this Satomi is the
real one that's gonna die derek is a
whole different story I feel like his
tragic arc is a false positive like he's
not gonna end up dying and he'll turn
the situation around and either get his
powers back or find a way to contribute
without them but on to benefactor
craziness number 2 Peter interrogate
Samara death based on the way they
presented it it seems like Peter is
lying about inception ting Meredith to
enact the Deadpool list
Meredith always wants to help so I
believe her more than I believe him I'm
still trying to decide which explanation
I like the most you know Meredith is the
true villain and she was lying about her
disability the whole time or Peter was
lying about inception occur I think
Peters only half lying yes I do think he
was lying about inception II Meredith he
probably used his alpha powers to Ghost
Whisperer Meredith whenever he was in
the hospital I think that was
intentional you have to remember when he
was in that coma it was like he was
trapped in a holodeck like he had
complete control of his mind he just
couldn't move his body I do not think
that he was lying about going crazy I
think he was being honest about that he
definitely went very crazy in that coma
the reason I think that he was able to
inception Meredith is because she had
just been taken to the hospital - so she
was in a state of shock and just
completely open to his psychic attack
but let's talk about Peter going crazy
under normal conditions I think he's
lawful neutral he could go either way
you know bad or good but after the fire
whenever he was trapped inside his own
body he went chaotic evil he had a dark
fantasy about taking power that he may
or may not have enacted but once he went
into the coma he just got pushed over
the edge so yes he is responsible for
everything but had he not been almost
burned to death
he probably would have come up with some
other less crazy plan that didn't
involve killing so many people like he
still would have tried to take power he
just wouldn't have been so maniacal I
always think that he's gonna be the true
villain of the series as he should be
but part of the fun is that he could go
either way like he's neutral he can help
people and he can hurt them at the same
time he can jump back and forth between
good and evil as it suits him he's like
the Tom Hiddleston Loki the series
except that he does not enjoy chaos
quite as much he wants control it's all
about order and control which leads me
to my number one WTF moment Peter wants
to kill Scott to get his alpha powers
back I should say tried to kill Scott to
get his alpha powers back but that's not
the end of the story
did anyone else wonder after that scene
between Peter and Kate if he's somehow
secretly orchestrated the fire that
killed his family - like so many years
ago I just think it would be a
masterstroke of villainy to give that to
the character he's definitely playing
Kate either way just like he's playing
everyone else but then working together
seemed like it only just started this
season so it's kind of hard to tell that
moment where they talked about killing
Scott gave me the vibe though that
they've been working together a lot
longer than that it was all about the
fact that Peter did not explain Meredith
to Kate like she already knew what
Meredith was doing her involvement in
the plan and during the dream sequence
whenever Peter was ranting about Talia
taking the family downhill got me
thinking he wanted to take control of
the pack but he needed to get rid of her
so he contacts Kate to seduce Derek as
the teenager and then convinces Kate to
set the fire if it's true that they've
always been working together Kate and
Peter I think that it was definitely
Peters idea to set the fire not Kate's
that would definitely make her character
a lot more sympathetic or at least seem
less crazy and Peter would be a much
grander villain like I said though I
don't think they're gonna be able to
kill Scott and I think that he's still
gonna get his alpha powers back by
killing Satomi there are a number of
other ways it could totally go down but
in order to make Peter a viable threat
in season 5 he has to power up somehow
which means he has to kill another alpha
but let me know what your favorite
moment is and let me know do you think
the Peter is gonna get his alpha powers
back in the finale I know I didn't
mention the yellow flower but does
anyone else feel like this is super
Wolfsbane or something like a Wolfsbane
a bomb a measure of last resort it was
being grown in the Argent's warehouse so
it has to be a weapon of some kind and
the only plant based weapon on the show
right now is Wolfsbane normal Wolfsbane
is purple though
why is this plant yellow that actually
kind of makes me feel like they're gonna
get to the point in the finale where
Chris feels like it's a lost cause and
it just sets the bomb off to just wipe
the slate clean overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus
I love the interrogation scene with
Peter and Meredith great crazy flashback
I always loved Peter being crazy it felt
like everything else in the episode was
just B story I did enjoy the setups for
the big characters and I'm really
looking forward to Liam getting his big
hero moment in the finale
Derek's also learned to contribute
without powers which is a big teaser for
season 5 I think and I really loved that
they left the cape Peter connection a
little vague like it's still unclear as
to how long they've been working
together even though I do think that
Peter is playing her for the fool all in
all I've been really happy with the way
they kind of got rid of a lot of the
supernatural aspects of the story from
three B it just made the characters a
lot more relatable just to give them
human problems and making Peter the big
villain again is always gonna be the
most fun configuration the show can have
as much of a bummer as it is to see
Derek losing the thing that made him
special I think it's a smart move if
he's gonna stay on the show which I
think he is I think he'll be back for
Season five Scott's always gonna be the
one true alpha despite what Peter says
so it really narrowed down the places
you could take Derek's character so now
in season five Derek has like a whole
new Derek that he has to learn how to be
which I think is gonna be just rich
territory for him it's like a reverse
Liam Ark liam learns how to fit in with
his new powers Derek learns how to fit
in without his powers like I said Teen
Wolf buddy-cop spin-off with Chris
argent Derek and Braden it would be the
most amazing show ever I didn't include
Parrish in that just because you can't
have a pair of show without Lydia and
Lydia is always gonna stay with the pack
but final thoughts are that I'm very
excited about the last two episodes it's
been a great season
way better than 3b in my mind but let me
know what your final thoughts are on the
episode and what you're looking forward
to seeing in the last two episodes and
if you haven't seen I've been posting
updates on Facebook and Twitter I'm
moving this week to a new apartment I'll
do a room tour video as soon as I'm done
but I'm a little bit behind on videos my
next team will post next week so be sure
to subscribe to get it if you're just
finding me it's the first time but I've
got some Marvel videos that I'm doing
tonight Donald Glover is actually gonna
get to be spider-man so the inner pipes
are leaking a little bit it's gonna be
really interesting to talk about I'll
totally explain what's going on with
that but right now click here to get
last week's Teen Wolf
and click here to catch up on Doctor Who
if you haven't been watching it
they just started series 8 episode 1
aired it is amazing you have to watch it
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives